[Music]  it's time for et social study your quick  look at what the stars are posting  online Dwayne the rock Johnson posted  that video along with a lengthy caption  back in August 2016 calling his mail  fast eight co-stars quote candy yet  seemingly referring to Vin Diesel but on  Friday then addressed the social media  drama saying the whole thing was quote  blown out of proportion and the Moana  star is known as uncle Dwayne in his  house she's alone my wife Kourtney  Kardashian shared this pic with her baby  daddy Scott Disick while vacationing in  Hawaii with their little ones  [Music]  [Applause]  and Jennifer Lopez shared that teaser to  Instagram of her upcoming Spanish album  along with these glam shots during  hashtag another day at the office  meanwhile John Stamos celebrated his  late mother's birthday hosting this  touching photo of her to Twitter  along with his close friend and actor  Don Rickles who recently passed writing  in part I miss you both madly  [Music]  you